SETH LADD: OK, awesome.
So I am truly humbled to see
this crowd here, and I want to
thank everyone for joining
us this morning.
This is really, really cool.
Disclaimer, there's only one
slide with Java on it, so
hopefully that's OK.
Just to get my bearings just a
little bit, I like understand
who's in the room.
But I asked a bunch of
questions earlier.
The last one that I'm really
curious about is who would
say, and to some degree that
they are a web developer?
Like, who would use
that title?
All right, cool.
And there was a big crowd that
also said that they were
server side developers, so
that's pretty interesting.
There was a big overlap there,
and we'll talk a little bit
about that.
OK, so welcome.
My name is Seth Ladd.
I'm a developer advocate with
the Chrome team focusing on
Dart these days, and we'll talk
a little bit about that.
This is really cool for me
because I feel like this is
kind of a hometown crowd.
I have many, many, many, many
years programming in Java on
the server side for me.
That's really where I think I
got my start and spent many
years, so it's very cool to come
back to a conference like
this and talk to you guys.
But then I spent a little bit
with Ruby on Rails, but then I
was lucky enough to get this gig
at Google working for the
Chrome team.
Little did they know, I
was not a JavaScript
ninja, if you will.
Again, having a lot of
experience on the server side.
But it was really cool learning
all about JavaScript
and HTML5, and the modern
browser and what's going on
there today.
And I spent the past
couple years
programming client side stuff.
So it's been neat for me to have
kind of the experience
and exposure across
the full spectrum.
But when I was programming the
browser, I always felt like I
wasn't quite getting my
expectations met the way that
I wanted to.
I think especially I was spoiled
a little bit working
with the tools and the languages
we have building--
Java is a good example, or C# is
another good one, in terms
of being structured
nature classes.
You know, libraries, packages,
et cetera.
And then tools allow you
to bounce around
the code really easily.
Refactor, rename, extract
method, all that good stuff.
And I really, really missed that
when I was programming
the browser.
Even though this is a super
exciting platform, I always
wanted to, I think,
program the way I
kind of grew up with.
And then so when I heard about
this project Dart, which
brings structured programming
with great tool ability to the
browser, so I get kind of the
best of both worlds, I jumped
all over it.
But then there was still this
kind of piece that was
missing, which was certainly
Dart as a language gives me
structure at the language and
runtime level, and the library
certainly as well.
But when kind of the rubber hits
the road in the browser
itself, I lost some of that
encapsulation, or structure,
reusability that again, I think
we all kind of take for
granted programming in
traditional structured languages.
And so when I heard about this
cool thing called web
components, I jumped all over
that as well, because that
allowed me to get the
encapsulation, the true
reusable widgets or components
that, frankly, almost every
other system out there already
has, and brings it via
actually the platform
into the browser.
I was very, very excited.
So I'm here to share both web
components and how the Dart
runtime and libraries bring all
this stuff alive today.
And by the way, I really
like it when
you guys ask questions.
So if something's not clicking,
please let me know.
And it gets a lot more
interesting when it gets
interactive, so don't be shy.
So today we're here to talk
about web components and Dart.
OK, so first we always
have to start off
with a demo, of course.
Now, here's x-gangnam-style.
That's a tag.
OK, so--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Cool.
So of course this works.
I feel a little cliche doing
this a little bit.
But I'm illustrating a point,
so just bear with me here.
So we see this fancy tag up
here, x-gangnam-style, which
looks like a fancy
HTML element.
Well of course, HTML doesn't
allow me to just introduce new
tags, or does it?
So I'm going to right
click on this.
Whoops.
Sorry, that's going to get
annoying real quick.
That's only seven more times
in the presentation.
So here we go.
You can see that.
Let me zoom in a little
bit here for you.
Sorry.
Let's scroll up again.
So actually in the DOM, in the
HTML explicitly is that
x-gangnam-style tag.
Which is great.
So I've introduced now into the
browser, or sorry, into
this page slash app a brand
new term into the lexicon
that's available
to me in HTML.
So you might say, well, what's
going on inside?
Well, actually, that's it.
That is the tag.
Now, there is this thing called
the document fragment,
and we can jump inside here to
see these sort of hidden
elements in here.
We'll talk about what these are,
but you can see the color
difference.
What I'm highlighting here,
x-gangnam-style, this is the
actual tag that the browser
and the DOM sees.
Inside of it is this hidden
shadow world of other DOM
nodes and elements and
attributes that actually make
up the implementation
of that tag.
And right away you're starting
to see some encapsulation,
you're already starting to hear
these word implementation
boundaries.
And so we're starting to bring
in this kind of declarative
nature of encapsulation into
the modern platform.
We'll see how we do this
in a little bit, but
that's really awesome.
And it's not just static.
We saw the animation, we saw
the sound, et cetera.
OK, something probably not as
totally hackneyed as "Gangnam
Style," but here we see an
example of x-megabutton, a new
tag that we've created which
shows off that you can
actually start composing
these things.
So this has a text node inside
of it, so they don't have to
be just kind of obtuse
elements.
You can start to interlace the
elements that you've defined
with the elements or attributes
of the page itself.
So if we hover over it here.
[MOOING]
OK.
But anyway, so it's funny.
It's funny because it's a moo.
But what I like about this
example here is the previous
example was just like, a random
element that I created,
although quite cool, and you
guys can go and use that.
But this element here shows the
inheritance capabilities
of these new custom elements.
This one actually is a button.
And one of the things that I've
always wanted to do on
the web platform since the
time that I started
was extend a button.
And now, and I see some nods,
they're like, yes,
why can't I do that?
Well, some of the capabilities
we're going to talk about
today shows us we can actually
start to do that.
Not just introduce new terms
into our lexicon, but extend
the existing behavior and
capabilities of the browser.
Pretty excited by that.
So many of you guys are like OK,
this is cool, but why do
we need to do this?
And hopefully a lot of you
guys are like, yes,
we need to do this.
But the thing that illustrates
this, the problem to me the
most is this slide right here.
Your left is viewing
source on Gmail.
Now, Gmail is by all accounts
a very complex, modern, full
featured application.
To pull that off, you need
something like this.
Now what I would want to see--
semantically what we're
trying to say is
what's on your right.
There's a list of messages, they
have subject and dates.
I don't know about you guys, but
the version over there on
the right, that is a much better
way to program the web
than the version over
here on the left.
Now what I'm not saying is that
divs are bad or anything
like that, but the version
over here, this is
implementation details.
This should be hidden, this
should be encapsulated.
There's no need for the DOM
itself to actually display
this, present this as the
structure of the page.
No, we want to talk about
a world where you
say what you mean.
We want to help usher in a
declarative renaissance and
help bring along the
world over there.
So that, to me, says
it loud enough.
So let's talk about web
components, as a way to bring
about this kind of declarative
renaissance in modern web
programming.
So there's a couple
parts of it.
The word web components is
really just a family of new
specifications and
functionalities getting
introduced actually at
the platform level.
The first one is a template tag,
which is the scaffolding,
or blueprints.
You could think of this as like,
inert chunks of DOM.
Once you have these inert
chunks, of course, you can
start doing things like
integrating over them and
putting them conditionals, and
interleaving, et cetera.
But you need a way to actually
have templates in your system.
Then you have this concept
of shadow DOM.
Now once you have templates,
you have to somehow inject
them into your page.
Now with the shadow DOM, you can
create that hidden shadow
world of implementation details
and bind it to a node
that actually does manifest
itself on the page.
And then finally, it kind of
all comes together with the
element tag.
And this is how you define new
custom elements and extend the
vocabulary of HTML today.
And again, bringing about
that say what you
mean programming style.
So let's start here by looking
in detail at templates.
Now of course, templates
are not a new concept.
And that's one of the themes
here of today's talk is that a
lot of this work with web
components is paving the cow
paths, if you will.
A lot of web developments have
been trying to do a lot of
these things for awhile.
And if you can bake it into the
platform, then of course
it becomes standard and native,
and you no longer need
to kind of reinvent the wheel.
And then more interesting
libraries and frameworks can
come about.
So we've of course been trying
to do this for a long time.
Here's method number one,
off screen DOM.
That is, you create a
DOM and you hide it.
But this has some certain
problems.
The first one is that this DOM
that's inside your hidden tag
is interpreted like every other
bit of DOM in your page.
So for instance, images
are loaded, scripts
are loaded and parsed.
And that's often not what you
want with a template.
For instance, think about if
you load up a template that
has some images but you don't
display that template for 10
minutes, why take the
hit to go get those
images right away?
The other problem with this
is this is all flat
within the same DOM.
And so it's very, very difficult
to create these
styling boundaries with a
template system like this.
And the list of problems
goes on and on.
OK.
Was there a question?
No?
OK, there's another way.
There's many ways.
There's another way that people
try to accomplish the
same thing, and they
do it through
overloading the script tag.
Well, we think that this has
problems because you're
completely bastardizing the
use of the script tag.
You're parsing a bunch of
text here as script.
You can easily introduce XSS
issues, and runtime string
parsing is always not
a good thing.
So we said OK, clearly people
want to do templates.
How do we bring those about and
into the platform itself?
Well, introduce a
template tag.
It's an inert set of markups.
So even if you do have things
like images in here, the
content inside the template tag
is parsed and created into
kind of an inert document
fragment, but it doesn't
activate it or execute it.
Now of course, once you have
this template tag in itself--
or the contents of the template
tag is itself a
document fragment, it's very
easy to then treat it like any
other thing you would in your
DOM or your web browser.
And this is another great
thing about these new
capabilities we're adding
to the platform.
You can play off and extend
things already baked into the
browser, things just move
a lot more smoothly.
So while these ideas and
concepts may be pretty
revolutionary, I think the
actual implementation of this
stuff and the actual kind of
delta between what you're
doing now and the new concepts
you're going to have to learn
are actually pretty small.
So here's a good example.
You can just go ahead and clone
the node like you could
clone any other node and attach
that template content
right into your DOM.
Pretty straightforward.
So we think that's
kind of money.
I could just stare into
those eyes all day.
OK.
All right, so those
are templates.
Inert set of DOM.
The next up is shadow DOM.
Now this is probably the most
complex concept, so we're
going to try to ease
into this.
So it turns out that browser
vendors have actually been
holding out on us.
It turns out that browser
vendors today actually have
this kind of concept of the
shadow netherworld that's
underneath your DOM.
And they use it to build--
here we go, there we go.
They use it to build some of
the components that we
actually use today.
So the perfect example here
is this video player.
If you're familiar with HTML5,
you'll know that this is a
just video tag.
So bracket video.
Which is great.
I just want to declare there's
a video in here.
But actually underneath the
covers, if we dive in, this is
just the dev tools which has a
flag turned on that says show
me the shadow DOM.
Underneath the covers there's
actually a set of divs in
here, and some of these divs
deal with the button.
And so we're actually able to
render the more higher level
composed widgets like the video
player out of what the
browser already gives you.
That is divs and buttons
and inputs.
And that's fantastic.
So browsers have been doing
this, and why wouldn't they?
I mean, it's a lot easier to
use the divs in here and
buttons in here than it is, I
think, to write a whole bunch
of C++ code.
Sorry, this is annoying.
There we go.
OK, and then so uses it in other
cases here, like the
date, widgets and
selectors, too.
So the browsers already have
this concept of reusing the
divs and elements and buttons,
et cetera, to build out higher
level functions.
So the shadow DOM just actually
exposes this to us,
so we ourselves can build
higher, more complex elements
that are made out of
the basic building
blocks of the browser.
And of course this means
encapsulation, which again, is
nothing new.
It's not a new concept.
But the fact that we're actually
getting in the
browser is going to completely
change the way
we build this stuff.
So let's look at this.
So the green nodes here-- the
actual document tree-- this is
the DOM that you're familiar
with, and you would walk with
your tools, et cetera.
The pink nodes, this
is the shadow DOM.
And individual elements from the
green, the normal or the
light DOM, can they themselves
host a shadow DOM
or subtree of nodes?
So yes.
This just shows that even though
the DOM that we all
see, the green node underneath
might have a shadow DOM, it's
the shadow DOM that's actually
rendered, much like we saw
with the video tag, even though
there's all those divs
and buttons in the video tag,
even though they're hidden in
the shadow DOM, they still
make up the rendering and
display of the element.
And this just highlights it
again, if you have a shadow
root, which is the green node,
itself has a shadow DOM, a
bunch of pink elements.
Underneath that shadow
root, there's a whole
bunch of those elements.
OK.
So it turns out it's very easy
to create shadow DOMs.
Again, you could do it off
of any other element.
We typically call those the
host elements because they
host the shadow DOM.
Simply create a shadow route,
and then off of that root,
again, you have this little
document fragment, and you can
assign some HTML to it, whatever
you would like.
In this case, remember the
shadow DOM is what's actually
rendered out.
So the top example here
is the DOM that's
statically in the HTML page.
Notice how it says my title
and my subtitle.
But the JavaScript area in the
middle creates the shadow
root, attaches a bunch of HTML
to it, and that itself is what
is being rendered.
So we replace any static
elements from the original
host element.
And I realize it's ironic that
this slide is probably the
least sexy, unstyled slide
ever, but I have a point.
And the point is once you have
these nice boundaries, they're
not just great for encapsulation
of the structure
of the element, they're great
for encapsulation of the
styles of the element as well.
And so the shadow DOM really
does a nice job with CSS
styles in terms that you
can assign styles here.
You can see it right there
in the inner HTML
for this shadow DOM.
And those styles are only
applied to the shadow DOM of
that element.
And now you're encapsulating
styles at the shadow DOM
boundary, which I think
is fantastic.
And notice how it doesn't
bleed out into
the rest of the page.
This is, I think, one of the
problems with some of the
earlier template systems
that we showed earlier.
It doesn't have that nice
styling boundary.
Now it turns out that it's much
more than just a simple
kind of brick wall boundary.
With the shadow DOM and its
scope style sheets, you can
interlace styles as well.
And that, I think, is
the real power.
Because up to this point, you're
like, yeah, I could do
this with iframes, sort of.
You know, there's a lot of
issues with iframes.
But what you can't do with
iframes, and what's really
slick about this stuff is you
can start to mix and match the
styles of the host page with the
styles of the shadow DOM.
And there's a couple different
triggers there.
One is reset style inheritance,
which says if you
set that to true, you say forget
about anything the page
is saying, let me just start
to control all this stuff.
And then apply author styles,
apply styles that the author
itself specifies in the host
page and kind of interlace it,
or let it bleed into
your element.
Now, the really neat thing about
this is that you as a
custom element author can
dictate the amount of control
and interlacing that you want to
allow your embedder of your
custom element to use, giving
you utmost control, but the
embedder authors utmost
style and flexibility.
OK.
So I'm going to skip over some
of these things here.
OK.
It turns out also that the
browser has been doing this
other tricky thing here called
custom pseudo elements.
Now for instance, here's
a range slider.
One of the great banes of CSS
development is how do you
style the browsers like the
more fancy kind of input
elements like dates
and range sliders?
Well if you really dig into the
actual source code, you'll
find that there's these
pseudo elements like
webkit slider thumb.
Firefox has some similar ones as
well that allows you to go
ahead and style things like the
range slider to be very
specific to your application.
Now, this is great because
this technique has been
applied to the shadow
DOM as well.
So you as a shadow DOM author
can declare the presence of
pseudo selectors.
Again, that's what's down in
here, which allows the
implementer of your custom
element, say, to style deep
inside of your shadow DOM
without understanding the
structure of your shadow DOM.
Again, encapsulation.
Bringing this to the
web platform,
super powerful stuff.
OK.
Another great hook
is CSS variables.
I really like this one because
it makes theming really,
really easy.
The bottom example here
is a bunch of CSS.
Am I saying this right?
Sorry.
The one at the top, let's
start with that one.
The one at the top says OK, as a
shadow DOM author, I can say
OK, there is some color defined
by some variable, and
I'll let the person who's using
me define what that
variable is.
And then of course the embedder,
or the person who
uses your shadow DOM can then
say OK, I'm going to set a
bunch of these variables, and
then that's how you can impact
the actual style declarations
of the shadow DOM.
Again allowing the author of the
shadow DOM to define the
right kind of points and
abilities for interlacing and
overriding these styles without
actually violating any
of the encapsulation principles,
which is, I think,
really, really fantastic.
So this brings us back to the
host node that we're talking
about, that top example.
When we assigned a shadow DOM to
the host node, we wiped out
completely his contents.
And I've been talking about this
whole interlacing concept
with styles.
Well, it turns out that we can
also do an interlacing concept
with the structure elements
of the shadow DOM as well.
So it is a way for us to
say hey, you know what?
I'm going to define a shadow
DOM, but I'm going to set
their particular insertion
points, or just kind of
markers for me to go back out to
the host's DOM's children,
pull then in, and slide them
into my shadow DOM so I can
interlace appropriately.
That was a lot, so let
me see if I can show
an example of that.
OK, so the version on your left
here, the host has the
H1, the H2 and the div.
Now, I'm going to implement a
shadow DOM over on your right,
and I'm going to define
content tags.
And they might have selectors,
like select H2.
These content tags are
the insertion points.
That's why I want to say OK,
I know I'm defining my own
structure that's encapsulated
inside the shadow DOM, but I'm
going to go ahead and pull out
particular elements and their
values from the host node.
Well, why is important?
Well, you may not know all
the details when you're
implementing a shadow DOM.
You may want to say, go ahead
and use my custom element, but
you may know what your title
is supposed to be.
So I'm going to go ahead and set
up a content, or insertion
point for the title, and I'll
take care of everything else.
Again, allowing you as the
author to define exactly how
these things are interlaced
without violating any
encapsulation.
So, yeah.
Cha-ching.
And also, when I always look
at these things, I always
stare in the background.
Like, there's a dude making
pizza back there.
What's his story?
I don't know.
I want to meet him some day.
OK, so now we talk about
some of these
elements, like, elements.
Like the template tag and
scope style sheets, and
insertion points
and shadow DOM.
That's all kind of the low level
infrastructure getting
added to the platform.
And you could certainly use that
low level infrastructure,
but where it all kind of comes
together in a really
delicious, layered lasagna
is custom elements.
And custom elements, you can
encapsulate three things.
You can encapsulate the
structure, that's
the template tag.
You can encapsulate the style,
that's the scope style sheets.
And you can encapsulate
the behavior.
This is any script tags
you may define.
And this all rolls up into a
nice new element that you get
to create and encapsulate
all this great stuff.
So it turns out that again, if
we're in HTML we can add a new
HTML element called element.
And this is how we can
define new tags.
So in this one, it's a
very simple example.
Element name x-tabs.
And note here the agreement with
the HTML spec guys, any
custom element names you guys
create will require a dash
somewhere in there.
So that's how you can sort of
visually distinguish between
custom elements and those
baked into the platform.
Regardless, custom elements
can define a template.
That's their structure.
Now, how do you use it?
Again, this is HTML and
this is the DOM.
And if we already have a bunch
of capabilities, let's not
reinvent anything, let's
use what we have.
So we have this great link tag
in HTML, and you can have
different relationship
type links.
Well, why not use that
for components?
So if you have the top element
tag in an HTML file, go ahead
and link that into your kind
of host page, and boom, now
you have access to new custom
elements, and you just define
them like you would any
other DOM node.
x-tabs, and it all just works,
which is very, very cool.
Now, OK, so I talked about
encapsulating structure,
style, and behavior.
Let's talk about behavior.
So custom elements can extend
existing elements, so you can
add fancy button,
extends button.
Which is fine.
You can interact with it like
a button, but you may also
want to interact with a
custom imperative API.
Well, you can do that as well.
It all works pretty
straightforwardly in
JavaScript here.
You can define a constructor,
and then you can define new
APIs you might call on
that actual element.
And this, I think, this totally
drives the point home
for me, which this is
totally what I want.
Well, this too.
Actually, all of it.
It's all really good.
So again, if they themselves are
elements, they themselves
are objects.
You can instantiate them
with nice constructors.
And remember, it really is an
element as far as the browser
is concerned, so you can work
with these things like you
would any other element.
And then you can call methods on
it like you would any other
element, too.
And it's just so fantastic
to finally be
able to extend button.
Just that one little thing.
OK, this drives the
point home.
You can extend elements
as well.
OK, so I'm doing OK.
So this is all awesome, and of
course, you guys are like, how
do I get access to
this right now?
I want to start encapsulating,
I want to start creating
templates and new elements, and
actually say what I mean.
And I want to bring forth the
declarative renaissance.
So the good news is that a lot
of this functionality like the
shadow DOM and the template
tag, these are coming to
Chrome really soon.
The other really good
news is this is not
just a Chrome thing.
These things are on the spec
track, and the other browser
vendors are very interested
in this work.
In fact, Firefox, Mozilla has
this great x tags project as
well, which you can look at.
And I have a very good,
optimistic feeling about this.
But there is another option to
bring this stuff alive today.
And of course one new family
of exciting features?
Why not two.
Let's up the ante.
So this is where we start
to talk about Dart.
Now, Dart is our
batteries-included platform
for building structured,
scalable web apps.
It's much more than
a language.
There's libraries, tools, a
virtual machine, an editor, a
package manager.
And it all compiles to
JavaScript, so it deploys
across the modern web.
But there's another really cool
thing about this, though.
The fact that we have this
compile step to compile
everything to JavaScript, we can
actually also compile all
the great web components work
that you might build with
custom elements and custom
templates all that stuff.
We can actually also compile
that all back down to vanilla
JavaScript and vanilla
HTML, which is great.
So that means that via the Dart
tool chain, you get to
use, actually, all the stuff
we're talking about today in
app that run across
modern browsers.
And you don't have to wait for
them all to implement with
these really cool features.
So it's very cool, and this
audience, I think, will
appreciate the design
of Dart as well.
So the question we always get
with Dart is why are you guys
building a new language?
And to which we say,
why progress?
Why innovation?
But really, it's about we
really want to help more
developers for more platforms
build more complex,
interesting, full-featured
offline enabled 60 frames per
second modern HTML5 apps
for the modern web.
And these are just some of the
screen shots of the types of
apps I think should be able to
be built by anybody in this
room with relative ease
and happiness today.
This should be possible.
And we're building Dart to
help make that possible.
So I'm going to try to blow
through this Dart stuff as
quickly as I can to get back to
the how do you actually the
web component stuff?
So forgive me if I
go a little fast.
OK, so there's one Java slide,
so I don't feel so bad.
Now of course, you probably
wouldn't write this code
exactly like this,
but I need to
illustrate a couple of points.
And so here is an equivalent,
yet more of the Dart code.
Now right away, you can say,
oh, OK, that's cool.
In fact, that actually looks a
little bit boring, which is
exactly the point.
We took a little flak when
we launched Dart.
People were like, why didn't
you build the next HasCl?
And we said, well, we wanted
more than five users.
So we knew that we needed
to have curly braces and
semicolons.
But as all you guys I
think can attest,
you're probably OK.
I think I can read that.
But we don't have to just
completely make it just
totally pedestrian.
We can say, hey, this is a
chance to, I think, clean up
some of the stuff that we
might be dealing with.
So I'm going to point out
a couple of features.
Yeah.
I'll just use this.
Couple feature that I think
really sell it.
So right away, we have full
support for classes.
So that's really cool.
OK.
What do we always do
in constructors?
This dot x equals x, this
dot y equals y.
This is getting really boring.
And we always name the method
parameters the same as the
fields for your class.
And Dart starts says, hey, if
they're the same, then just
simply put this dot in front of
the constructor parameter.
And this is syntactic sugar for
we'll take care of this
dot amount equals amount.
So I love that.
The next great thing is
named constructors.
Now, Dart is an optionally typed
dynamic language, which
means you don't have
method overloading.
Which is not a big deal in
methods, because of course you
can create any named methods
that you want.
But in constructors, typically,
in traditional
structure languages, the name of
the constructor is the name
of the class.
So we introduced named
constructors here to help to
differentiate the different
types of constructors and what
they may do.
Which I love, because for
instance, you might think of
an object, you might have that
can take a string that might
be either be XML or JSON.
So in Dart, you can easily say
person dot from JSON, or
person dot from XML, even though
they both take strings.
So the call site itself gets
really, really clear.
We're going to jump down here.
We have method overriding,
so you can do
plus, minus, et cetera.
And then actually this and the
two string here use the fat
arrow syntax for simple,
one line functions.
Excuse me.
So this is just syntactic sugar
for return amount dot
two string, et cetera.
Now, these simple, fat arrow,
one line functions are perfect
for things like event handling
when you want to kind of in
line the handling of callbacks
or events.
And then one other thing I think
just to point out here
in the syntax, this bad boy
right here wrapped in curly
braces is an optional
parameter.
So you may or may not,
or you can or cannot
pass in charge tax.
And because it's an optional
parameter, we also have
default values.
In this case, faults.
So hopefully it looks familiar,
but also cleans up
and adds a little bit nice
syntactic sugar and terseness.
OK, who knows JavaScript, and
who knows what this would do
if this was JavaScript?
This would blow up.
In Dart, we have lexical this,
which is fantastic.
So in Dart, what you see
is what you get.
How you write the code,
statically analyzable.
Everything's lexical scope,
including this.
And so everything just
works, and, oh,
this is the old syntax.
So I'll change that.
Note to self.
OK.
Now, I mentioned earlier that
Dart was a dynamic, optionally
typed language.
Now, what does that mean?
You can start writing your
programs without the use of
static type annotations, which
is great because at the very
beginning when I'm just starting
out my brand new idea
that I'm going to sell to Y
Combinator for a jillion
dollars, I don't have to worry
about cumbersome, complex
class hierarchies right
when I get started.
I don't have to worry about
abstract class factory, class
factories, and all that stuff.
I just want to start writing
code that works.
Once I get comfortable with the
design and things start to
lock down, then I start adding
the type annotations in.
So when we say it's a scalable
language, that's
kind of what we mean.
Now, of course you could write
code like the top, but then
you better pray somebody wrote
comments in there.
But then even if they did write
comments, then the tools
don't know how to read it.
And so what we generally
recommend is use the type
annotations like this and
like this, et cetera.
Here's the return type.
Use the type annotations at the
surface area of your code.
So any code that you're going to
give to another developer,
say interact with, use the type
annotations, and I think
we all can attest to
why that is good.
OK, so back to the browser.
Making our way back to kind
of web components here.
When you build a new language
and new libraries like with
full collections, et cetera,
we want to take this
opportunity to also make
programming the browser feel
very natural and native to
Dart programming as well.
Everyone knows the DOM, the
DOM is language agnostic,
which means it never feels
very natural to anybody
programming in an actual
language, which partly
explains why JQuery is so
popular, and made programming
the DOM feel like JavaScript.
So we can make programming
the DOM feel like Dart.
And again, if we have actual
support baked into the
platform for real collections,
then why not use those same
collections and their
semantics and
APIs for the browser?
So we can use real constructors
like new button
element, and if classes is
just a collection of CSS
classes, then this is
an actual Dart list.
And you can interact with those
CSS classes like you
would any other Dart list.
Add, remove, index, all
that good stuff.
Here's a good example of how
you might have an on click.
So a done on click dot listen.
Now what's going on here, this
is using our Streams API for a
stream of events.
When you bake into the platform
these abstractions
that everyone can use, now HTML
events, file I/O, network
I/O, all these things can
now all use exactly the
same type of API.
So programming the browser feels
like programming Dart.
And even child nodes can be
themselves Dart collections.
So I guess the point here is
if you know how to program
Dart, then you'll know how
to program the browser.
But we seem to be repeating
button here all the time.
So again, I think we can be a
little bit more terse and
helpful, and for all you small
talkers in the room, we
brought along method
cascades as well.
And so what I like about this
is it's really fantastic for
builder-type APIs.
Like the DOM--
you're always doing DOM stuff
like set the ID, set the
classes, set the display
property,
et cetera, et cetera.
The neat thing about the double
dot syntax here is they
all apply to the first
expression before that first
double dot dot.
But then the really neat thing
is what's actually returned
from this whole thing here is
that first expression, which
is why button is equal to a
new button element, which
happens to have text classes,
et cetera, et cetera.
So I like this.
I really like this.
It's nice syntactic sugar.
OK, we're getting close.
So now that you're writing
browser programming, you might
be saying, well, how
do I get-- oh, yes.
Question at the top?
[INAUDIBLE]
Is there someone in the
back can drop the
spots on the screen?
Is the font hard to see?
I don't know.
Sorry.
I'm not sure.
I can try to--
yeah, sorry.
OK.
We'll see what I can do when
I pull up another slide.
OK, so we think compile all this
stuff to JavaScript via
our Dart JS compiler.
So everything we're talking
about here today gets deployed
across the modern web,
mobile, and desktop.
Now, that's all cool.
But of course, the compilers
like GWT or Dart to JS are
spitting out code generated by
machines for machines, which
means they've been obfuscated
and minified, et cetera.
Now, that is hell on people
that want to debug stuff.
So our Dart to JS compiler also
spits out a source map.
Now, a source map is a really
cool file that says OK, take
the input, the Dart code and map
it to the output, which is
JavaScript.
And so that you can say OK, this
line over here actually
maps to these lines, et
cetera, et cetera.
Now, why is this important?
Well we can go over to the
Dart Editor, and this
hopefully looks really
familiar.
So part of the Dart project is
an editor that's been built to
help you edit Dart code.
Also, IntelliJ has an Dart
plug-in as well.
But what I'm going to illustrate
here, I'm just
pulling up one of the samples.
And we're going to run
as JavaScript.
So it's compiling the Dart code
into JavaScript here.
OK.
Kind of cool.
We got some solar
system stuff.
But again, so this
is stock Chrome.
This knows nothing about the
Dart language or the Dart
virtual machine, or anything.
So we're going to open up dev
tools, and we're going to
break this out.
And we're going to
go to source.
And already here, listing in
the sources of dev tools we
see Dart, Dart, Dart,
Dart, Dart.
Which is actually kind of cool,
because that means my
dev tools, even though it
doesn't know anything
intrinsically about Dart, it's
being told via the source map
that hey, hide the JavaScript
that's generated and present
to the developer, the debugger
all the great Dart code.
So let's just scroll down to--
there's kind of a
good place here.
Yeah, OK.
So let's set a break point.
So I set a break point on Dart
code in Chrome dev tools,
which via the source maps
actually sets the right break
point in the JavaScript.
And you can see that the program
itself stops running.
And we can use traditional kind
of debugging as well, as
we can move through this.
OK, we see the planets changed,
and all the cool x
and y stuff.
So I guess the point here
is that yes, we're
writing Dart code.
Yes, we're compiling JavaScript,
but the debugging
story is still really good.
Let's kill that.
Oh, here.
OK.
So another really neat feature,
if you've got a
statically analyzable language
with optional types and a
strong tool set is you get to
deal with a problem that
plagues web development today.
So to set it up here, size,
of course, is incredibly
important to any web
app developer.
Now this is why if you go to
any, say, JavaScript library
out there, the top marketing
material they always have is
how small they are, you know?
JQuery gets to Zepto, Zepto
goes to Dojo, which has
literally I think something
they call Nano.
Well, that's good.
Of course you want to pay
attention to the library, but
you're still paying the complete
library tax every
time you include one of these
libraries in there.
Well, it turns out that,
again, if you have a
statically analyzable language,
you can perform a
technique called tree shaking,
which takes a holistic look, a
whole world look at your
program, follows it from the
start all the way through the
possible paths, including all
of the linked in or imported
libraries, and generates a
pruned, or tree shaken
conversion of that application
such that it only contains the
code and the function, the
classes that you actually
use in your program.
So this here illustrates it.
We're importing a library which
itself has some methods,
and even our program has some
methods that are never used.
And what's generated in the
output is simply just the main
function and the two functions
that we actually call.
And our Dart tool chain actually
does this for you, so
you can now start looking at
libraries and packages that
people make in terms of how good
they are, instead of how
Femto they are.
So I think that's
kind of cool.
OK, one last demo of the Dart
ecosystem here is our package
management.
We affectionately call
it Pub, because you
play darts in a pub.
But the neat thing about this is
just like Node has NPM and
Java has Maven, and Ruby has
Gems, we have a neat system
called Pub, and I'll just
illustrate that really quickly.
Let's load up an app here.
I've only written seven lines
of code, but I've imported
three different packages.
Each of these packages I didn't
write, but I was able
to go ahead and use a simple
YAML file to declare those
dependencies.
And if we go up here,
the tool chain.
And don't be fooled.
You can run all this stuff on
the command line too, I just
happen to like running
all the stuff.
So now it's going on to the
interwebs, and it's
downloading all the packages,
symlinks, everything.
So when we go back--
that's a bug.
OK.
Now they're gone.
And now we can run the
program, and here.
Everything just works.
They're so cute.
But what's really awesome about
this is I only wrote
seven lines of code.
And of course, again, talking,
I think to Java, of course
this should just
work like this.
But the widget itself
is a package.
The frame itself as a package.
The cat pic itself
as a package.
And because you have classes and
libraries all baked into
the language, you can compose
these things very, very simply
and know while you're editing
if it's going to work.
So I really like it.
And you can go onto Pub, you
can see database drivers on
there and crypto stuff, and
all this neat stuff.
OK.
Oh, and we have a virtual
machine to
run Dart code natively.
There's no compile step.
It's much more like Ruby or
Python, you just run the code.
And of course, if you're
building a new VM, and the
guys that are building the Dart
VM and leading the Dart
project are actually
also the guys that
built V8 and HotSpot.
So if anyone knows how
to make stuff fast, I
think it's these guys.
And it's still early, but I
think we have a good runway
here for us.
OK, cool.
So that's the short, short,
short, short,
short version of Dart.
Let's bring it back to Dart
with web components.
It's like peanut butter
and chocolate.
But for me, it's about
programming with tools, and
the library and languages that
exactly meet and exceed my
expectations, especially coming
from my background.
And also building with these
encapsulated, reusable
components and widgets
on the web today.
OK, so that brings us
to Dart Web UI.
This is really where the
rubber hits the road.
The Dart Web UI package is a
web components polyfill.
A polyfill is library or code
that makes a new feature
available to developers today.
So you don't have to wait
for everyone to go
implement the stuff.
But on top of the web component
stuff, the stuff
that we saw earlier, which was
the declarative a new elements
and templates, the web UI also
has declarative dynamic data
driven two-way live
data mining.
I think that was a lot of buzz
words, but we'll see an
example of that in a moment.
This is very similar, I think,
to angular, if you guys are
familiar with angular.
And something that's very
important to us is very fast
developers cycles.
One thing I want to make crystal
clear, and we'll see
in a minute is that because
we're talking about a compile
step, does not mean you have
to wait for any of
this stuff to happen.
In fact, right now it's on
the order of hundreds of
milliseconds to make all
this stuff work.
And as is the common theme with
all this stuff, it all
compiles on vanilla JavaScript
and HTML, and works across
modern browsers today.
Cool.
Let's get to the demo.
So the very first thing
we're going to show
is simple data binding.
How are we doing so far?
OK.
Cool.
All right.
Let's do the first one here.
So this is data binding.
How's that?
OK?
OK.
This is an HTML file,
a Hello World.
Couple things I want to
point out to you.
The double curly braces.
This defines the data binding.
So I have some variable called
superlative that I want its
value to appear here, and I
want not only its value to
appear here once, I want
it to be live bound.
So any time I update
superlative, I want the
infrastructure to go update
this point in
the HTML right here.
Another neat bit here is the
declarative event handling, on
dash click equals change it.
Does what it says.
So let's look at
the code here.
I think one of the important
points about this is very
declarative embracing
the DOM, right?
So it's all just in the HTML.
Here's the Dart code that you
would write to make this work.
Here's the superlative
variable that
we're talking about.
Here's the change it
top level function.
Neat thing about Dart, top level
functions just work.
So you don't have to wrap
everything in classes.
And when this runs, it simply
says set the superlative
variable from some random
set of alternatives.
OK.
So let's go up to the compiled
version, and
let's just run this.
OK, MDV.
MDV stands for Model
Driven Views.
It's a series of techniques and
behavior to do basically
what it says.
Take your models and drive
the views dynamically.
Let's go ahead and click that
button, and of course it's all
working, and of course the
random, it sometimes picks the
same number.
But you get the idea.
But the neat thing here is that
I only declaratively set
up the button, and I said
when it's clicked,
go call this method.
And then the other thing I
declared is hey, put whatever
is in superlative here.
But the web UI package, which is
what's driving all this has
all the data binding watchers.
It has the dispatcher and sets
up all the generated code for
us to make all this
stuff work.
So that's cool.
Let's skip over this because I'm
running out of time here.
Conditionals.
OK, this is a good one.
OK.
So here's another HTML file.
Again, it all really starts in
HTML, which is hopefully a
common theme here.
Just be very declarative,
work with the DOM.
Here we go.
So we've got a div here that I
want itself to be a template,
but I want this template to only
render if language choice
is not null, and language
choice is not empty.
So again, I'm just being
very declarative
about all this stuff.
But remember, the templates from
earlier, this is exactly
what we're talking about here.
And then we also have one way
data binding here from the
selects value to set this
language choice.
So you can reason about this
application simply by looking
only at the HTML, which
is really cool.
If the select ever changes,
update the
value to language choice.
And then if language choice is
ever not null or not empty,
render the contents
in this template.
So we can do this one really
quickly as well.
Now, this stuff's been
all-- actually, here.
I'm going to show a demo.
OK, so this is the Dart
code for person.
And then notice how I have
nothing selected, so the
template isn't rendered.
And when I do have something
selected, the
template does render.
But let me just show you how
fast this workflow is.
Hello.
Jfokus.
OK, ready?
Saving the file, going back
over here, reload.
Boom.
It's that fast.
And what happens is the editor
is watching for changes to all
these files.
If it notices any of my source
files change, it kicks off
this build script, itself run
in Dart, which runs the
compiler to all the
[INAUDIBLE]
JavaScript.
And by the time they get back
over and reload the page, it's
all working.
And so that's what we mean by
really fast developer time,
which is really important
to web development.
Web development is much--
the reload is your compiler.
OK, I am so out of time, so
OK, let's do one more.
Let's show the custom
elements here.
And we're going to look at the
ludicrously simple to-do.
I think to do is like
the new, or do you
always hit the right.
But this is a little bit
more complex than that.
It kind of pulls it
all together.
So here's my ludicrously
simple to-do app.
Let's just put this in here
so it makes it quieter.
Let's see.
I've got a button to create
new to-do items.
I've got a list of to-do,
and here's my custom
element to-do item.
And I'm binding in the Dart
object, the model object that
is a to-do item into this
new custom element here.
So let's just look
at what this is.
Here's our custom element.
It has a name, it has a
template, it has a script that
points back over to
the behavior.
Here's where we define the
actual behavior of the element
that we are creating
in our world.
And notice that this is very
much like an MVVM, pattern so
we have our models, and then we
have our view models, which
are essentially the
custom tags.
So let's just go ahead
and run this.
We see all this running.
And I'm running in Dartium,
which is a build of Chromium
with the Dart VM in it, which
makes testing even faster.
So learn Dart.
OK, you've attended my talk.
So, whoops.
Check, done.
So anyway, custom elements,
data binding, real nested
models, all that stuff
just works.
OK, cool.
OK.
I think I can squeeze this in.
If you've ever seen the
TodoMVC, we have an
implementation of that.
Everyone's implemented this, but
what I really like here is
who's familiar with
Twitter Bootstrap?
OK, awesome.
So Bootstrap is a very easy to
use set of CSS conventions,
but also some dynamic widgets.
So of course the light bulb
should be going off and saying
hey, dynamic widgets, we
have web components.
And so we've implemented almost
all, if not all, the
dynamic widgets in bootstrap
actually as reusable web
components, and now the dream
has finally come true, right?
This is really, really cool.
So you can actually deal with
it in terms of custom
elements, x-accordion,
x-collapse, and it just all
works, and it's just
so beautiful.
You say what you mean.
You don't have to deal
with any of that.
And then the custom element
itself implements the dynamic
code required to make the stuff
work, so you don't have
to go get this other
JavaScript file
and include it in.
It just all is encapsulated
very, very nicely.
OK, so the summary here.
Web components.
They're coming to the
web platform.
Composable, declarative,
and reusable.
You can of course build with
them without Dart, as you saw
on all the earlier stuff,
it's JavaScript as well.
But we also think you might be
interested in this thing we
call Dart for structured,
scalable, and familiar web
programming.
And we think they go really,
really well together.
In fact, it's one of the only
ways to bring a lot of the
stuff alive today and deploy
it across modern browsers.
So hopefully you give
everything a try.
All this Dart stuff
is open source,
very permissive license.
Everything you saw today is all
available in the package
manager, and we crave
feedback.
We love it.
We're an open source
project on purpose.
And so please do let us know
what you think, and again, I
really appreciate
everyone's time.
I'll be hanging around here
for questions afterwards.
Thanks very much.
That's all I got.
[APPLAUSE]